in the end most fundamentally
literally the mother of all problems
is
who designed us so so assume
success and that we're going to
transition to the machines making
machines and all of these new sort of
social systems we're describing will
help manage them and curate them and
democratize them
if we close the gap I just let off with
of 10 to the 10 to 10 to the 18 between
chip Fab and you
um we're ultimately in marrying
communication computation and
Fabrication going to be able to create
unimaginable complexity
um and how do you design that
and so I'd say
the deepest of all questions that I've
been working on
is
goes back to the oldest part of our
genome so
in our genome what are called Hox genes
and these are morphogenes
and
nowhere in your genome is the number
five it doesn't store the fact that you
have five fingers
um what it stores is What's called the
developmental program it's a series of
steps and the steps have the character
of like grow up a gradient or break
symmetry
and at the end of that developmental
program you have five fingers
so
you are stored not as a body plan
but as a growth Plan and there's two
reasons for that one reason is just
compression billions of genes can place
trillions of cells but the much deeper
one is evolution doesn't randomly
perturb almost anything you did randomly
in the genome would be fatal or
inconsequential but not interesting but
when you modify things in these
developmental programs you go from like
webs for swimming to fingers or you go
from walking to wings for flying it's a
space in which search is interesting so
this is the heart of the success of AI
in part it was the scaling we talked
about a while ago and in part it was the
representations
for which search is effective
AI has found good representations it
hasn't found new ways to search but it's
found good representations of search and
that's you're saying that's what biology
that's what evolution has done is
creative representation structures
biological structures through which
search effective and so the the
developmental programs in the genome
beautifully encapsulate the lessons of
AI and this is It's embody it's it's
molecular intelligence it's AI embodied
in our genome it it it it's every bit as
profound as the cognition in our brain
but now this is sort of thinking in
molecular thinking in how you design
and so
um I'd say the most fundamental problem
we're working on is it's kind of
tautological that when you design a
phone
you design the phone you represent the
design of the phone but that actually
fails when you get to the sort of
complexity that we're talking about and
so there's this profound transition to
come once I can have self reproducing
assemblers placing 10 to the 18 parts
um you need to not sort of
metaphorically but create life
in that you need to learn how to evolve
but evolutionary design has a really
misleading trivial meaning it's not as
simple as you randomly mutate things
it's this much more deep embodiment of
of AI and morphogenesis is there a way
for us to continue the kind of evolution
of design that led us to this place from
the early days of bacteria single cell
organisms to ribosomes and the 20 amino
acids you mean for human augmentation or
for Life augment I mean what would you
call assemblers that are
self-replicating and placing Parts what
is the the the dynamic complex things
built with digital fabrication what is
that that's the light so yeah so
ultimately absolutely
if you add everything I'm talking about
it's building up to creating life in
non-living materials yes and I I don't
view this as copying life I view it as
driving life I I didn't start from how
does biology work and then I'm going to
copy it I start from how to solve
problems and then it it leads me to in a
sense ReDiscover biology so if we go
back to Valentina in Ghana making her
circuit board she still needs a chip Fab
very far away to make the processor
owner circuit board for her to make the
processor locally for all the reasons we
described you actually need the Deep
things we were just talking about and so
it really does lead you so let's see
there's a wonderful series of books by
gingery
book one is how to make a charcoal
furnace and at the end of book Seven you
have a machine shop
so it is it it's sort of how how you do
your own personal Industrial Revolution
uh isru is what NASA calls in-situ
resource utilization and that's how do
you go to a planet and create a
civilization uh isru has essentially
assumed gingery you go through the
Industrial Revolution and you create the
inventory of a hundred thousand
resistors what we're finding is the way
you the minimum building blocks for a
civilization is
roughly 20 parts so what's interesting
about the amino acids is they're not
interesting they're hydrophobic or
hydrophilic basic or acidic they have
typical but not extremal properties but
they're good enough you can combine them
to make you
so what this is leading towards is
technology doesn't need enormous Global
Supply chains it just needs about 20
properties you can compose to create all
technology as the minimum building
blocks for a technological civilization
so there's going to be 20 basic building
blocks based on which the
self-replicating assemblers can work
right and I say that not philosophically
just empirically sort of that's that
that's where it's heading and
yeah that I like thinking about how you
bootstrap a civilization on Mars that
problem there's a fun video on bonus
material for the movie where where with
a neat group of people we talk about it
because it has really profound
implications back here on Earth about
how we live sustainably
what is that Civilization on Mars looks
like that's using a isru that's using
these 20 building blocks and does
self-assembly yeah go go through primary
secretary tertiary quaternary
um you know you you extract properties
like uh conducting insulating
semiconducting uh magnetic uh dielectric
flexural these are the kind of you know
roughly 20 properties
um with those
those are enough for us to assemble
logic
and they're enough for us to assemble
actuation
um with logic and actuation we can make
micro robots
the micro robots can build bigger robots
um the bigger robots can then take the
building block materials and make the
structural elements that you then do to
make construction and then you boot up
through the stages of a technological
Civilization by the way where in the
span of logic and actuation to the
sensing come in oh I skipped over that
but my favorite sensor is a step
response so if you just make a step and
measure the response to the electric
field
that ranges from user interfaces to
positioning to material properties and
if you do it at higher frequencies you
get chemistry and you can get all of
that just from a step in an electric
field so for example once you have time
resolution in logic something as simple
as two elect electrodes let you do
amazingly capable sensing